un ciclista empieza a pedalear y acelera
por 12 segundos la velocidad vedette del
ciclista cada 2 segundos en pies por
segundo está dada en la tabla y aquí nos
dan diversos valores de tiempo a los 4
segundos la velocidad de 7.5 pies por
segundo a los 8 segundos la velocidad es
9 pies por segundo considera la gráfica
de velocidad contra tiempo velocidad
contra tiempo sea r mayúscula de 6 la
suma de las áreas de 6 rectángulos
circunscritos con sus intervalos iguales
entonces r mayúscula de 6 es una
aproximación de la distancia total
recorrida en pies durante los 12
segundos cuál es el valor de r mayúscula
de 6 te invito a que le pongas pausa al
vídeo e intentes hacerlo por tu cuenta
posteriormente lo haremos juntos y en
cualquier momento si te sientes
inspirado podrás ponerle pausa y
terminarlo por tu cuenta
veamos qué es lo que nos están diciendo
dice considera la gráfica de velocidad
contra tiempo graphic hemos pues los
puntos en este papel gráfico me voy a
enfocar el primer cuadrante
pues los valores de tiempo y velocidad
son ambos positivos veamos entonces este
es el eje del tiempo este es el eje de
la velocidad como función del tiempo
vemos que los valores de tiempo van de 0
a 12 de dos en dos vamos a marcarlos en
la gráfica aquí tenemos 0 2 4 6 8 10 y
12 y la velocidad tiene valores que van
desde 0 hasta 10 vamos a marcar los 1 2
3 4 5 solo voy a identificar algunos 6 7
8 9 10 esta es nuestra velocidad que
está en pies por segundo mientras que el
tiempo está en segundos
graf y queremos pues los puntos entre
igual a 0 la velocidad de 0 gente igual
a 2
la velocidad es 6 pies por segundo entre
igual a 4
la velocidad es 7.5 pies por segundo
gente igual a 6 la velocidad es 8.5
entre igual a 8 la velocidad es
gente igual a 10 segundos la velocidad
es 9.5 pies por segundo y finalmente /
igual a 12 la velocidad es 10 pies por
segundo y lo que he hecho aquí es
graficar los datos que nos han dado ya
tenemos la gráfica de velocidad contra
tiempo de acuerdo a los datos que nos
proporcionaron así es que podemos
imaginar que aquí va una curva vamos a
dibujar una curva que pase por estos
puntos la curva que representa la
gráfica de la velocidad en función del
tiempo la cual es más o menos así ela y
esta es la gráfica de velocidad contra
tiempo veamos ahora cómo calcular la
suma de las áreas de seis rectángulos
circunscritos con sus intervalos iguales
cuando indican sus intervalos iguales
están considerando sus intervalos
iguales para la variable independiente
en este caso el eje del tiempo como
estamos considerando un intervalo de 12
segundos cada sub intervalo va a tener
una duración de 12 entre 62 segundos
vamos a marcar entonces esos rectángulos
el primer vídeo en 2 no voy a usar otro
color mejor
aquí tenemos no parece otro color bueno
es azul no voy a usar mejor un color que
contraste más aquí tenemos entonces los
rectángulos cuya base es 2 y solo he
puesto el inicio del trazo pues
necesitamos determinar cuál va a ser la
altura pues aquí nos dicen que tomemos
rectángulos circunscritos y que son
rectángulos circunscritos bien eso
quiere decir que la altura va a estar
determinada al evaluar la función en el
extremo derecho del sub intervalo así
entonces para el primer rectángulo cuyo
extremo derecho son dos segundos la
altura va a ser la velocidad a los dos
segundos que es seis pies por segundo
esa va a ser la altura del primer
rectángulo para el segundo rectángulo
esta va a ser la altura y aquí te
podrías preguntar cómo serían los
rectángulos si no fueran circunscritos
es decir rectángulos inscritos en los
cuales la altura se toma evaluando la
función del lado izquierdo así es que
para el primer rectángulo por ejemplo en
el extremo izquierdo la función vale
cero para el siguiente rectángulo el
extremo izquierdo está en dos segundos
así es que la altura para este siguiente
rectángulo son seis así es que para el
segundo rectángulo inscrito la altura
sería esta de aquí
más o menos así sería el rectángulo en
fin nos están pidiendo rectángulos
circunscritos hagamos rectángulos
circunscritos déjame borrar esto bien
perfecto así es que este sería el primer
rectángulo circunscrito aquí estaría el
segundo sólo voy a dibujar las partes de
arriba el tercero el cuarto el quinto y
el sexto vamos a completar los
rectángulos aquí tenemos el segundo este
es el tercero este de aquí es el cuarto
rectángulo el quinto y finalmente
nuestro sexto rectángulo circunscrito
bien ahora nos están diciendo que r
mayúscula de 6 es la suma de estos
rectángulos y nos dicen que r mayúscula
de 6 es una aproximación de la distancia
total recorrida en pies durante los 12
segundos y por qué es eso porque la suma
de estas áreas es una aproximación de la
distancia total recorrida bien
mucho antes del cálculo aprendimos que
si teníamos una velocidad constante
entonces la distancia recorrida es igual
a velocidad por tiempo precisemos que
esta velocidad es constante pero la
velocidad en este ejemplo está cambiando
el ciclista está acelerando sin embargo
podríamos aproximar la distancia
recorrida si suponemos que la velocidad
puede ser constante por intervalos en
este caso intervalos de 2 segundos
ahora cuando tomamos estos rectángulos
circunscritos a veces enfoquémonos en
este primer rectángulo cuando cálculo el
área de este primer rectángulo que estoy
haciendo
estoy multiplicando la altura por la
base la altura es la velocidad del
ciclista a los 2 segundos y la base es
el intervalo de 2 segundos cuando
multiplicamos 6 pies por segundo por 2
segundos
obtenemos 12 pies vamos a escribirlo
aquí el área de este rectángulo es igual
a la velocidad aunque de hecho en la
rapidez pero no nos vamos a preocupar
ahorita por la dirección del movimiento
la velocidad seis pies por segundo
multiplicada por dos segundos y eso nos
va a dar igual a doce pies doce pies eso
obviamente es una aproximación pues el
ciclista viajo a cierta velocidad que no
era constante pero la pregunta es la
aproximación está subestimando o
sobreestimando el valor verdadero bien
en este caso claramente la aproximación
está sobre estimando pues estamos
tomando la velocidad a los dos segundos
que es la mayor del intervalo
el ciclista empezó a cero pies por
segundo así es que aquí estamos sobre
estimando la distancia te invito a que
le pongas pausa el vídeo y te des cuenta
que si los rectángulos hubieran sido
inscritos estaríamos subestimando la
distancia pues multiplicaremos la menor
de los ida del intervalo por la longitud
del intervalo recordemos que esta es una
aproximación calculemos ahora rd6 rd6 es
igual al área de este rectángulo que
como dijimos es que como hemos calculado
es igual a 6 pies por segundo por 2
segundos esto es igual a 12 pies a eso
le sumamos el área de este rectángulo
que va a ser
ambos esto es 7.5 pies por segundo x 2
segundos esto es 15 pies así es que más
15 y aquí podemos ver en el área al
rectángulo que va a ser 3 pies más 12 y
la mitad de 2 que hay aquí es decir 3
pies más y luego tenemos el área de este
rectángulo que va a ser 8.5 pies por
segundo la velocidad al final del
intervalo multiplicada por dos segundos
esto es igual a 17 más 17 pies más esta
área que es la velocidad al final del
intervalo que es cuánto es esto es 9
pies por segundo por 2 segundos esto va
a ser igual a 18 pies más 18 pies y
luego tenemos esta área de aquí que
vamos a calcular como la velocidad al
final del intervalo que es 9.5 pies por
segundo multiplicado por dos segundos
más 19 pies
19 y más finalmente esta área que va a
ser la velocidad al final del intervalo
10 pies por segundo por dos segundos más
20 y esto cuánto nos va a dar veamos y
aquí es donde suelo cometer errores
aquí tenemos 12 más 15 esto es 27 más 17
10 37 más 7 44 esto va a ser 44 más
18 44 10 54 y 8 62 más 62 44 más 18 son
62 más 1962 más 1981 y más 20 esto es
igual a 101 pies así es que erre
mayúscula de 6 es igual a 101 pies es
una aproximación para la distancia total
recorrida durante 12 segundos que en
realidad es una sobreestimación pues
para cada intervalo estamos suponiendo
constante la máxima velocidad de ese
intervalo si tomáramos la menor
velocidad del intervalo
los rectángulos serían inscritos y
estaríamos subestimando esa distancia
una mejor aproximación se obtendría
promediando esas velocidades por ejemplo
si tomáramos la altura aquí en tres para
este primer rectángulo o algo similar
pero esto lo vamos a ver en futuros
vídeos